This is I'd Like to Know, our Bible
question and answer program here at
SumTV and Secrets Unsealed. Thank you
for joining us and sharing a little of
your no doubt busy day with us. My name
is CA Murray. To my right, Pastor Steven
Bore, our founder and president. to my
left, Pastor David Salazar, general
manager of our Latino network. And we
are thankful, as we say again, that you
are with us today because the program
just wouldn't be the same if you were
not part of our experience. Should you
want to have a question answered by us
and we hope uh that you will send your
questions in, send them to TV at some
suum as in MarysumTV.org.
You can see it right there on the
screen. TV tvsumtv.org.
og and we will get to your question just
as soon as we can. We get questions from
all over the world. May we encourage you
when you send your question, give us
your name, at least your first name, and
let us know where you're writing from.
It helps us to know what our foot
footprint is and uh what is troubling,
what uh questions you have all over the
world. And we do get questions from all
over the world. Pastor Steven Bore,
would you uh ask the Lord's blessing on
this particular sitting and then we'll
write out right launch out to our first
question. Thank you.
>> Let's pray. Father in heaven, so many
questions,
questions that uh we can't even find
answers to.
>> And in this program, we do our best to
find answers to the life and death
questions that come in.
We ask Father that you'll be with us as
we address these questions that have
been so generously sent to us. I ask
Lord that uh the answers will be
satisfactory to those who ask them and
we look forward to the day when we'll be
in the kingdom and uh Jesus will be our
instructor and there's no question that
he will not be able to answer.
>> We long for that day. We ask that you'll
prepare a place for us and bless us in
this program. and we pray in Jesus name.
Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. I want to say just before we
read into our first question, there are
many Bible question and answer programs
that get callins and get questions that
they take on the fly. We tend to like
this format a little bit better because
it allows us to delve into the biblical
question and to get uh as much
information for you as we possibly can.
So we tend to move a little bit slower,
cover a few less questions uh on air,
but we feel that if you take the time to
write the question, we ought to give you
a thorough answer to your question, if a
thorough answer can be given, not
something that we just give off the top
of our heads. So that's why we we've uh
developed this particular format because
it gives us a chance to study your
question, to study into your question,
and give you as in-depth an answer as we
possibly can. Having said that, our
first question comes from Lee or less
rather Jay. Um, we don't know where he
is writing from, but he says, "Greetings
to pastors Bora Murray and Salazar." So,
we get called out by name at the very
beginning. Uh, thanks for your
remarkable work. Thank you, Le Les, for
that observation. I have a puzzling
question that I've been trying to
understand.
When the sinner comes to repentance and
has turned their life around, is that
person is that person still labeled a
sinner? So he wants to know, are you
still labeled a sinner once you have
given your life to the Lord?
I I think that um you know it's a good
question that our friend is sending us
because it really shows that he's either
studying and wants to know what is the
process of someone becoming free from
that declaration of being a sinner from
being one in emity with God uh one that
is not in harmony with the Lord and one
that has been forgiven and so I think
that's a good question uh I do think
that we have to present what the Lord
says to us in for example Romans 5:1 in
that verse that is well known. It
presents us what happens when we receive
what is called justification by faith.
It says there in the book of Romans and
verse five I mean chapter 5 verse one.
Therefore,
having been justified by faith, we have
peace with God through our Lord Jesus
Christ. When we have faith in Christ,
when we are justified by faith, and
justification means asking to be
forgiven, confessing our sins, repenting
from our sins, and accepting the Christ
righteousness in our lives. We be we
change from being in emnity being
sinners being separated from God to
become or become uh friends or sons of
God and having peace with God. We're no
longer in emnity. We're no longer in
distress. We are with Christ. We are
declared just. So the justification by
faith as you confess as you repent as
you come to the lord gives you that
complete understanding or that complete
uh declaration of the lord that you are
justified by having confessed your sins
and repented from your sins and coming
to the lord. So the first thing is you
be you stop being a sinner as as you
accept the lord in your life and you
accept his right righteousness in your
life. remaining
uh friend with God is the process of
sanctification. What keeps you enables
you to continue in that walk with the
Lord. And so I I think that answering
the question to a certain degree is that
is the first step is in justification by
faith. You stop being a sinner. You
become a friend with God. You're in
peace with God.
>> I would add to that Romans 8:1.
>> There is therefore now no condemnation
to those who are in Christ Jesus. When I
looked at the question,
>> my mind immediately said, "This is a
question of justification by faith.
>> You are righteous with God because God
says you are righteous with him."
>> He says, "Through your faith, I give you
credit for righteousness that you do not
already possess."
>> Yes.
>> So, while I am making you righteous,
which is a sanctifying experience, I'm
declaring you righteous, which is a
justifying experience. So, you are
technically still a sinner. When's the
last time you sinned?
>> Good question.
>> So, why are you not a sinner? Because
God has declared you righteous,
>> right?
>> And and and he makes that statement. You
you are you are a sinner but you through
your love of Jesus, your faith in Jesus,
your surrender to Jesus, I take that and
give you credit uh for being righteous.
So technically you're still a sinner,
but as God sees you, he sees you through
the eyes of Jesus and can declare you
righteous. It's it's a great I want to
say plan because while God is making you
righteous if at any time you die in the
faith, you die with a declaration of
righteous on you. So God is taking to a
you to a place, but he gives you a
credit a credit for being in that place
even while you're still walking to that
place, which is the the the nexus of
justification by faith.
>> We're accepted in the beloved. towards
the use the words of the apostle Paul.
>> Yes.
>> Um you know Martin Luther once expressed
it this way uh and I'll use the Latin
and then I'll explain what it means.
Simulustus
at the same time righteous
simul
at the same time a sinner.
>> And how does that work out?
Simo penitencia.
In other words, at the same time a
sinner, at the same time righteous
because you're declared righteous.
>> Yes.
>> And at the same time because you you are
declared righteous. You are always sorry
for your sins.
>> And you're always coming to the advocate
with the father, Jesus Christ the
righteous. If any man sins, he has an
advocate with the father, Jesus Christ
the righteous. It doesn't mean that
justification
is forever.
>> Uh justification
uh has to be linked with sanctification
as we saw in our uh in our summit this
year.
>> Um you know but you know people don't
have to be all the time self-conscious
and saying am I saved and am I not
saved? Am I saved? Am I you can have the
assurance of salvation.
>> Amen. As long as you're in Christ, as
long as his life and his death are
credited to my account, God doesn't look
at me. He looks at him.
>> Amen.
>> Because I accepted him. He's my
representative.
>> He's my advocate.
>> He's my attorney, if you please. Yeah.
>> And as long as I continue claiming him
as my attorney
>> and I hate sin
>> and I repent of sin and I confess my
sin, you know, my status doesn't change.
Justified, unjustified. Justified,
unjustified. Uh, you know, assured, not
assured, assured, not assured. No, we
can have permanent assur as assurance as
long as we cling to Jesus Christ and we
hate sin and love the Lord.
>> Absolutely. And you know in the Bible we
have pastor several examples of
individuals even before Christ's coming
who were called by the by the word Lord
just individuals. Noah was called just
men um of course Abraham, Job and uh
>> Rahab
>> Rahab a lot of a lot of individuals
women and men and none of them you could
say oh they became sinless. They were
you know never committing a a mistake.
They committed mistakes but they didn't
stay or they didn't hold on to the sin
in their lives. They would as the Bible
says this judgment will fall but seven
times seven times fall but he will wake
up or raise up seven times. That is
experience is you don't stay in that
condition. If you made a if you lose uh
a a battle, you go back to the Lord, you
repent from your sin and you hold on to
the Lord. That experience in spite of
you being
uh in that struggle with with temptation
as you are leaning to the Lord, as you
hold on to the Lord, you are
strengthened and you are growing in an
experience where you might not be a
perfect individual as far as like
sinless, but you are growing
consistently in the Lord. And that is
what makes a person in in in that path
uh a a friend of God, a just man or a
just woman. And so you don't have to,
like you said, doubt the mercy of God.
You don't have to doubt about your
salvation. As long as you're holy to the
Lord, as you have a relationship with
God, as you as long you're walking with
the Lord, he will make sure that this
process that he started in you would be
finished.
>> Yeah.
>> You you I'm sorry.
>> I don't want to cut you off. Our parents
don't forsake us or hate us when we
fall,
>> right?
>> We're still we're still the children,
right?
>> Uh and so God doesn't forsake us
>> when we sin.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh you know, we repent. And by the way,
repentance is not crocodile tears.
Repentance means that you see how
terrible sin is
>> and that it offends Christ. It led
Christ to the cross. Yeah.
>> And therefore, we long to overcome sin.
So it doesn't hurt Jesus.
>> Absolutely.
>> That's true repentance.
>> Exactly.
>> Um I'm not talking about people whose
repentance is to kind of get off the
hook.
>> That that is not true repentance.
>> Or to fear uh punishment,
>> right?
>> Fear of punishment does not mean to
repentance. Just, you know, look at the
examples of the Bible. People that
repented, they would act upon the
promises of God. And by faith, it will
lead them to obedience, to a behavior
change, to a desire to live a godly
life. Uh but if you are holding on to
your sin and not wanting to let go of
that vice or whatever it might be that
the Lord, the enemy is holding you, then
you're not really experiencing
justification by faith, which God wants
you to experience if you submit yourself
to him.
>> Yeah. I have a friend I grew up with, uh
bless his heart, I know him well. uh
every time he goes to prison, and he's
been in prison a lot, he gets saved, you
know, he he gets he repents, uh he comes
out and he goes back to the same way.
And this is at least half a dozen times.
>> Um he sins and repents and sins and
repents and sins and repents. That's not
what it's the Bible is talking about.
Yeah. Um a um I want to commend you to
Romans 4:3 and Galatians 35 and 6 which
say basically the same thing that
Abraham believed God and was credit to
him for for righteousness. a thing that
you referred to, pastor, um, 1 John 2:1,
if we sin, we have an advocate with the
father, right?
>> Which sounds a little counterintuitive
to 1 John 3:6 and 1 John 3:9, which say
that if we're in Christ, we don't
>> we don't sin. But of course, it means we
don't practice sin. We don't live in
sin. We don't wallow in sin. We are on
the upward path. For if your foot slips,
if you make a mistake, uh, as we all are
want to do, you have an affictate with
the father. You're still God's child. He
does not abandon you. He doesn't turn
his back on you. You've got someone to
take care of that should you make an
occasional mistake.
>> And the bottom line is that when you
first receive Christ into your life,
>> Yeah.
>> and are justified, you're a you're a
little baby in the faith.
>> Yes.
>> And after that comes growth. Growth.
Growth. Uh let me ask you uh do uh
little babies who are a few months old
do they uh stand up and try to walk?
They fall and they hit their head on the
table? Of course they do.
>> But eventually do they learn how to
walk?
>> Yes they do.
>> Yeah. So are are new Christians going to
have stumbles and falls? Are they going
to go back to what they were doing
before and so on? Of course. But what is
the key?
>> Grow.
>> The key is to get up. Yes.
>> Get up and keep growing.
>> That's right. and ask the Lord for
strength to walk.
>> Amen.
>> Uh and uh you know the the more time
goes by that we depend on Christ, the
closer we come to him and the less we
fall.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. The truth is as you look
over your walk with Christ, you ought to
see some divine interposition. You ought
to see God putting his hand in your
life. You ought to be
>> really better in 2025 than you were in
2015. There ought to be some growth.
ought to be some strengthening um as you
look over your life. Now, are you still
making some mistakes in 225? Well, of
course you are.
>> But you're drawing closer to Christ. You
understand your mistakes. You don't
wallow in your mistakes. And you never
go back. You're always forward. Praise
the Lord.
>> Christ Jesus. I think the the the
theology
of justification, sanctification by
faith is one of the greatest, most
comforting uh
>> uh theological concepts that the
Adventist Church has. Uh the fact that
you can be justified while you're being
sanctified is a wonderful wonderful
>> Amen.
>> All right. So I think we've exhausted
that question. We've got time to get
just another in. This one is coming from
Stan. Am I looking at Stan?
>> Yep.
>> From um again we don't have a place he's
writing from, but he asked this
question. I've never understood fully
the synagogue of Satan. Please explain
Revelation 29
specifically
uh who were or are the people who claim
to be Jews and are not? And then what is
the synagogue of Satan? Um who's got the
the the text? Pastor, you got it.
>> I have them.
>> Okay.
>> Uh he quoted Revelation 2:9. And so I'm
going to read Revelation 2:9. It says,
"I know your works." This is just so we
understand. This is the message to the
church of Ismyra. It says, "I know your
works, tribulation and poverty, but you
are rich and I know the blasphemy of
those who say they are Jews and are not,
but are of a are a synagogue of Satan."
So this is the verse in in Revelation
2:9 that speaks that, but it's also
mentioned the same term synagogue of
Satan in Revelation 39.
Mhm.
>> And this is the two parts on the only
two verses of the Bible that actually
have that same word. So I want to read
that as well. Revelation 3:9. And this
is actually to the church of
Philadelphia. It says, "Indeed, verse 9,
Revelation 3:9, indeed I will make those
of the synagogue of Satan who say they
are Jews and are not, but lie. Indeed, I
will make them come and worship before
your feet and to know that I have loved
you." So if you notice in those two
verses we actually see uh the same
phrase used and again the main the main
thing that is declared that it says they
are Jews and are not both of them it
says the same phrase they are
>> supposed to be claim they claim to be
Jews but are not correct now are these
speaking of the actual physical you know
Jewish people
>> of course not this is a this is a a
language declaring those who are
supposed to be believers, supposed to be
Christians, supposed to know the truth,
the Bible, the word of God, but they
just claim to do God's word, but indeed
they actually are doing the work of
Satan, the work of the enemy, the
assembly of those who pretend to be of
God's people, but are actually doing the
work of Satan among the church of God.
>> Yeah. The bottom line is that the book
of revelation
is saturated with Jewish terminology.
>> Yeah.
>> That applies to the church.
>> Correct.
>> Right.
>> Uh you have for example um in the church
of Pergamum.
>> Uh you have Balum. They have the
doctrine of Balum.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, Balum was a a prophet that lived
in the Old Testament,
>> right?
>> But this is talking about the church.
>> Yes.
>> You have the church of Thotyra. It talks
you allow that woman Jezebel. Well,
Jezebel was long dead at that time.
>> Mhm.
>> Um and and so now you have the synagogue
of Satan. Uh the synagogue was a Jewish
meeting place.
>> It wasn't a church meeting place.
>> Mhm.
>> So what's happening? You you have Jewish
terminology.
>> Yes.
>> That is applied to the church.
>> Because there are similarities between
the Old Testament experience
>> and the fulfillment in the church. So
the key thing that we need to do is
identify what a Jew is in the church
age.
>> Is it a literal Jew uh that has Hebrew
blood running through his veins? No. We
allow the Apostle Paul to define uh what
a Jew is. And there are several texts
for example Romans chapter 2 verse 28
and 29. For he is not a Jew,
>> who is one outwardly outwardly
>> outwardly.
>> Um, nor is circumcision that which which
is inward in the flesh. But he is a Jew
who is one inwardly. And circumcision is
that of the heart, in the spirit, not in
the letter, whose praise is not from
men, but from God. So there are Jews
that are not really Jews. Yes,
>> there are physical Jews that are not
really Jews according to this. Paul also
said in Romans chapter 9 and verses 6-8,
but it is not that the word of God has
taken no effect. For they are not all
Israel
>> who are of Israel.
>> Correct?
>> Nor are they all children. It's
understood by of Abraham. Nor are they
all children because they are the seed
of Abraham.
>> But in Isaac your seed shall be called.
In other words, the Messiah comes
through Isaac. That is those who are the
children of the flesh. That's literal
Jews. These are not the children of God,
but the children of the promise of the
Messiah are counted in the seed. And
then there's Galatians 3:29. If you are
Christs,
>> then you are Abraham's seed and hes
according to the promise.
>> So, who is a Jew today? someone who has
embraced truly Jesus Christ as savior
and lord.
>> Uh we also have um in John 1 and I'm
going through this quickly. John 1:es 47
to 49 the experience of Nathaniel.
>> Uh Jesus says this is a Jew indeed. This
is a real Jew. Why? Because he confessed
that Jesus Christ was the Messiah.
>> You are the king of Israel. You are the
Messiah. Um uh if I could just maybe
read um one passage which is kind of
long but it makes the point. The the
literal Jews of Christ were not really
Jews,
>> right?
>> They weren't descendants of Abraham.
>> You say no. Yes, they were. They had the
blood of Abraham. Yes. But notice what
Jesus said to a group of Jews. John 8 uh
beginning with verse 39. They answered
and said to him, Abraham is our father.
Mhm.
>> Jesus said to them, "If
you were Abraham's children, you would
do the works of Abraham."
>> But now you seek to kill me, a man who
has told you the truth which I heard
from God. Abraham did not do this. You
do the deeds of your father. Then they
said to him, "We were not born of
fornication." In other words, you don't
we don't know who your daddy is. We have
one father, God. Jesus said to them, "If
God were your father, you would love
me." Yes.
>> For I proceeded forth and came from God,
nor have I come of myself, but he sent
me. Why do you not understand my speech?
Because you are not able to listen to my
word. You are of your father the devil.
>> They're not children of Abraham.
>> Yeah. They're not.
>> They're father of the Because the devil
wanted Jesus.
>> Precisely.
>> So it says you are of your father the
devil and the desires of your father you
want to do. Mhm.
>> He was a murderer from the beginning and
does not stand in the truth because
there's no truth in him. When he speaks
a lie, he speaks from his own resources
for he is a liar and the father of it.
So let me ask you, who would the
synagogue of Satan be in the light of
this? It's somebody who rejects Jesus
Christ as savior and lord.
>> But but the but the word synagogue is
applied to the church. Jewish
terminology applied to the church, but
it has to do with with true Jews versus
counterfeit Jews in the synagogue of
Satan.
>> I think the important thing is you don't
want to read too much into synagogue as
though or some club or some group of
people meeting in a particular place.
It's a mindset. Uh uh the the
seven churches of course are roughly
defined by seven time periods. My Bible
breaks it up as the loveless church, the
persecuted church, uh the dead church,
um the compromising church, the lukewarm
church, the faithful church. Uh and this
of course is a persecuted church. So as
you continue to read in Revelation 2,
you see that uh what comes behind that
is to prepare them for persecution, to
prepare them to be opposed, uh to be
fought against. So the synagogue of sin
is just that group of people who have
this antichrist mindset who will be
fighting against you aso as opposed to
thinking of of them as a a church group
per se. It's a loose group of people who
simply reject Christ and are fighting
against this new church uh and is is the
persecutor.
>> And because they're the synagogue of
Satan, they claim to be Jews, but
they're not really not. They claim to be
Christians,
>> believe it or not,
>> but they're really not. Yeah. Well, a
couple of things that I wanted to say,
but our time is up.
>> I know time has gone by
>> again. Time flies faster than having
fun. We'll see you again soon on another
I'd like to know. God bless. We'll see
you again. Bye-bye.